[Musique]
alors qu'est ce qu'on a aujourd'hui
oui il est arrivé et ça il est bein je
me suis dit au rendez vous et c'est pas
il a pas il n'a pas donné son prénom
oui oui c'est bien être sa vie qui met
quoi décroche sa valda et les jeunes pop
a ha c'est pour le nez c'est ça non on a
dû vous charriez au collège sur le pas
du tout j'aime pas autre chose oui bah
je vous écoute comment je m'appelle oui
non et c'est une question comment je
m'appelle absolument voyez voulais pas
le dire si je m'apprêtais à bah oui mais
non
alors là je dois avouer que je
m'attendais pas à voir ici
y'a pas de problème avec le prato là
d'une certaine manière si qu'est ce
qu'il ya quelqu'un lui a jeté un sort
encore une fois ça va me saouler ça non
non il est tranquille dans la
bibliothèque
ok mais bon c'est quoi le problème vous
voyez bien j'ai beau être la magicienne
à plus doués de toute ma génération il
n'a toujours que pour as we pratta vous
bien merci
ah oui par 6 à 8 par là vous avez
combien de fois par jour on dit le mot
oui c'est plus 2006 beaucoup
et combien de fois on dit hermione
granger moi à part quand on faisait
l'appel en classe jamais ok bah je vais
au nom là vous les peler bouge pas je
l'écris non ouais qu'est ce qui vous
amène ici je trouve que j'ai pas fait
beaucoup de points cette saison là vous
êtes quand même le meilleur marqueur de
la saison avec 2500 points au total
oui mais la saison d'avoir en effet
combien 8000 et celle d'avant plus 9000
donc moi je demande pourquoi il y en a
pas plus cette saison je suis tout à
fait au courant mais je peux pas bouger
les lignes c'est un truc comptable à la
con savez que j'ai fait une potion
magique
bon bah du point ce midi j'ai
débarrasser la table
alors ça c'est bien ça c'est 25 âge
était sympa qu'un poufsouffle 14 points
et vous savez pourquoi on n'a jamais de
pointe parce que vous êtes mieux parce
que c'est quasiment impossible de dire
sans point pour tous sous 100 points
pour pau ce bas je l'avais s'est jusque
là je me suis arrêté avant 100 points
pour pau samba boursoufle sans point
pour vous voyez c'est pour ça qu'on est
nul
non vous êtes nuls parce que vous êtes
nuls ça marche
[Musique]
c'est quoi ça à part un pur aux noms ce
blog est magique
ouais les autres endroits du bois
exotique des plumes de phoenix et moi
j'ai un parapluie rose
oui mais tu es puni c'est pour ça donc
le parapluie ça passe quand même vu
parce qu'il y en a toujours pour
gryffondor ils font dans la menoua sous
prétexte qu'on et serpentins on est
forcément des connards et en même temps
vous êtes un connard oui bah voilà bah
je me dis point pour répondre en quoi
mais c'est des jeunes algériens fait la
critique et me joins 100 points au
compteur excusez-moi j'ai oublié de
préciser en fait tout à l'heure j'ai
fait pitié j'ai baissé la lunette à la
fin ça c'est magnifique ça 400 points
pour gryffondor vous êtes sérieux car
vous avez raison 400 s'est passé saint
saëns un sahraoui soyez attentifs ah oui
et notre emblème y aurait moyen de le
changer parce que moi j'avais pensé à un
tigre c'est stylé un tigre les styles et
intègre mais ça ressemble trop au lion
des raisons d'ordre une truite alors un
tourteau langoustines
aucun animal marin une huître go et les
points pour gryffondor mais quoi encore
mais moi je me pète les rouleaux à faire
une meilleure position à sauver les
miches de tout le monde à faire des
sorts hyper dur je chope 16 points ah
oui ils débarquent ils attrapent une
petite balle dos reis et sont en direct
vous m'expliquer ok vous savez quoi je
vous mets trois points pour les rendre
au café le couple il m'a dit coudonc ça
c'est 50 points bombay font non mais
[ __ ] je fais ce que je veux
un faucon maltais n'ont toujours pas un
pélican nom tout comme nom paul folle
dingue mode 'crise' en fin de mois je
vous fais des pros balles qui sont un
peu mieux que ce que tu as pires que ça
se voit sur mon visage que je ne te des
gamins face oui alors j'étais sûr que
vous diriez un phasme mais c'est un
blaireau ça restera toujours à méreau
maintenant le camp donc en récapitule
bol de mort voilà le malade oui mais
c'est mon prêt mais c'est à moi ça on
peut remettre ça va plus tard potable
j'ai besoin juste entendre une fois
quelqu'un de venir
d'accord et bien voilà
ce serait pour prendre rendez vous avec
un beau noël sous les couleurs
de rien
au thunder mais ça fait tellement
plaisir de vous revoir alors déjà moi
c'est gandalf et vous commençait
sérieusement à me briser avec votre
école à la con l'ancienne école à la con
quand même c'est plus tard la gueule
[Musique]
salut les potters aide si vous avez
envie de découvrir la chambre des
secrets de ce sketch vous pouvez cliquer
ici
et si vous aimez particulièrement le
bureau des plaintes et qu'il ya une saga
qui vous plaît laissez le nous en
commentaires
on la fera peut-être et sur golden
moustache tu sais quoi il ya d'autres
vidéos là par exemple